so in the world cup there's 127 players
and they play a knockout system so after
one round they're 64 which is good for
chest the second round is going on
currently and there were nine Americans
that nine fingers there were nine
Americans to start surprisingly for went
to the second round five got knocked out
Shabbo al Qaeda not halt I can do this I
can do it just think I can I think I can
uh what see who else is terrible yeah I
mean I I got the bottom of the barrel
here what else
Alejandra Ramirez man I was Armageddon
game and I'm missing one one other
American got knocked down the first
round
yeah I'll think of it in a second I mean
I want people going on where Ray Robson
gotta calm ski Hikaru Nakamura and pause
pause ownership ownership in Rob's that
got knocked out today owner shook in
most embarrassing fashion okay
ownership lost the first game and it's a
two-game match now if you're good at
math and you lost Game one of a two game
match guess what you have to do in game
to offer a draw and after 20 moves in an
equal position that's what he did so
he's out yeah I don't know ridiculous
ridiculous um ray Robson lost the first
game against Eve on truck and tried
really hard the second game but not hard
enough so so he's out
Nakamura's through and calm ski won the
first game and the whole lecture will be
on the second game considered by many
including myself the worst game ever
played by two players 26 50 feet above
so like it's a bubble game for you guys
but every move double question marks
you'll feel right at home
pressure I don't know okay now
Ashima knov unlike ownership actually
tried to win the second game and he did
was amazing
so tiebreak tomorrow while there's many
tie breaks but this is the important one
so there's one America
doing tiebreaks I'm sure you're all very
patriotic because of the great u.s.
victory yesterday in what's that soccer
very good beating ah worse the answer
I've ever heard man I've heard some bad
answers from Ken West but that's your
getting up there now bosnia-herzegovina
and it's the first time the US has been
behind in Europe ever and one ever
that's very suspicious two days ago the
Cardinals did the same thing they were
Oh in 40 this year when behind after
eight innings but then they want as I
was watching back okay well obviously
was cheating involved okay so uh this is
a very funny game because I want to talk
about strategic ideas because that's the
name of the class you're very familiar
or you should be with the Queen's Gambit
the strategic idea of the Queen's Gambit
is that this guy leaves the board see
that was easy and when he does you get
the center and black plays probably here
if you're in my camp and then and then
White has this nice position okay and
that's if he's one of the better players
right back me up Julian ah do you do you
agree this is checked wait let's check
me okay ia what does a Gris mean okay so
what we're trying to do is take this
pawn that's sort of on the side sort of
and get rid of the center pawn so we can
grab the center it's a very common
opening most grandmasters don't take the
pawn they play e6 or c6 to maintain
their pawn on d5 the King's gambit has
similar ideas except you get checkmated
a lot yeah what are you going to do so
Shimon oov played very unusual Kings
gambit which I want to play because I've
been playing over morphe games lately
and morning wins so why can't I win okay
and and incorrect as usual what's your
name
Julian always incorrect says I'm
stronger than morphine and I would win
horrible yell at him yeah yeah no
ridiculous okay so more views play an f4
and
crushing people and he's facing a
foreign crushing people now I had an
acquaintance slash friend and bish again
and he would come over the house and
play chess with me my dad my brother and
I mom would feed him that's the main
reason he came over and he actually got
220 350 but he was maybe 1,300 at the
time and his favorite player was Worf II
and he asked my mom once he says you
know I don't really know the answer to
this getting a chest question my mom
that's that's the bottom of that makes
our chests campers look good by the way
and he said it's morph you still alive
and she and my mom knows nothing about
Chad said no even sheena she's like not
now he died in the 1870's all right so
I'm like I looked it up but I was like a
yesterday so I forgot exactly okay so
morphe was the king of the Kings gambit
which makes sense
don't tell the Brawn right now against
the Kings game that I play d5 causing
confusion calm ski instead thought for
20 minutes at every move until he was in
time trouble I move seven good idea
and he took which is the correct move
and now if you remember Judit Polgar
when she was good that's a good memory
you gotta have a really good memory to
remember that what did you always play
in this position because Bishop c4 right
and most grandmasters like Nigel when
he's kidding or Spassky when he's not
kidding
play Knight f3 and then Fischer said d6
wins because he's crazy which he later
proved that he was crazy it improved d6
was good he proved he was crazy okay
this ship c4 now I have my own story
which always happens because I'm old I
have this position with black against
Judah and I prepared for and I had a
novelty prepared and it was all thousand
years ago and when I played my novelty I
remember the game at all she instantly
moved and played faster than me and was
winning I'm not winning but better
exactly right and then in a draw an
endgame of double rooks she walked in
the meetin won the crowd didn't like
that when I checked me to Judah the
crowd was mad because they were rootin
for her she was like 14
so she was only like 200 points better
than me okay so Bishop c4 is what Judith
and when she Manav who's whitened this
game your favorite Grandmaster played
this calm ski thought forever again and
I met Chi Minh off wall I didn't meet
him but I saw him in India 2011 at the
world junior championship and he did
pretty well okay he was drunk a lot
anyway d5 is the normal move and if pawn
takes the bishop is blocked they take
with the bishop and now you play Knight
f6 question incorrect in this position
yeah Bishop e3 ah is that a good plan no
no now then your bishops terrible you're
not developing that's typical low rated
player thinking very good I'm glad you
said that
so most low rated players they don't
care about development they don't care
about the center they care about being a
pawn ahead so white wants to play Bishop
b3 and c4 which may be a plan but I
discouraged my students from doing that
the difference is your moves were legal
very good I've been teaching camp all
day and I don't see that too often okay
and you actually had a reason for making
your moves I've never seen that before
not in chess camp okay so taking what
the bishop is the normal move that's
what you did it against me
because you want to have open lines and
if you remember the Queen's Gambit which
was like three minutes ago so White's
trying to get the center so II D sorta
destroys his center he'd like to play d4
and e4 and Shima have actually
accomplishes that because cops key plays
crazy later Bishop takes Knight c3 and
white wants to play Knight f3 g4 Bishop
takes f4 and be a pawn ahead and have
the center Bishop b4 which is a
reasonable move Knight f3 I never saw
people developing their pieces so much
I've been teaching chess camp all week
what happened to Queen h5 Queen h4
blundering their queen castles castles
yay
c6 Bishop c4 now cops key went
completely nuts
which I like because it wasn't me and I
was showing this game of the chess camp
today and I was telling him playing the
sander and develop your pieces and conky
did the opposite just to prove me wrong
b5 a5 like what okay
ridiculous okay so I told the kids
Black's not developing at all he pushes
all his pawns on the side I said so the
wind just to prove me wrong okay but he
didn't prove me right should have won
oka for stopping a 497 takes takes
Knight d5 and now white wants to play
pawn c3 and pawn d4 and Bishop takes f4
and he does all that stuff that's a good
plane to have them to do it and black
for some reason did this but I don't
know why and cops he's terrible no okay
although he will win these things field
Cup Knight takes bishop the mysteries of
life Bishop takes he actually saw his
rook was hanging now Rick a6 is a funny
move I've only seen a play by good
players in the Budapest when I say good
they're not too good
and black wants to play rook h6 and give
me also he's saving his rook but that
only works like in one minute chest
which this is not
although comps he had one minute now so
it was was close okay d3 attacking the
pawn on f4 Knight f6 attacking the
bishop bishop hides on a to nine h5
defending the pawn on f4 typical
actually Kings gambit move protecting
the pawn on f4 and white decides to get
a good center always a good time to do
that and 95 which has a what's a called
discovered attack yes I only teach at
seven times a day okay
so 95 and the Queen on g1 is attacking
the knight and calm ski just missed it
and hung Apple I should have okay now he
played Queen h4 so the kids were happy
because there's a queen on h4 that's
that's how you play and queen of d3
attacking the b5 pawn and rook gates
now blacks play is very weird and calm
skew she doesn't play weird and Nakamura
likes to play weird so he was probably
watching this game shaking his head at
both sides okay and then he went back to
his own game and shook his head some
more okay not sure why but he by the way
if you listen to Lauren Stretton Sue and
Susan Polgar because you've some wrong
with you if you listen to them horns
Trent just says Nakamura keeps shaking
his head and that's that's his
commentary like what you think the
position
I don't know how Nakamura shaking his
head that's the commentary look at his
shaking his head odd it's true now my
computer program says whites winning and
it says the best win is Knight f7 rook
f7 queen tase b5 because you know this
is pinned and then this is going to be
hanging this is hanging this is matin
one in case you don't see it what you
probably don't if Bishop d7 I'll take it
because the rooks pinned and my computer
says white is up four point six which is
good for white okay
another winning move is Bishop takes f7
with the same idea in fact you can just
keep taking things every move and then
Brooke takes a5 attacking the bishop
with check and then take on b5 and
whites up like two point seven it says
so white has lots of ways to win instead
white played the worst legal move in
chess history okay and that's I mean I
walked throughout you guys place I'm
shocked I thought I couldn't see worse
moves but man he this one makes no sense
at all it's not terrible horrible only
jacob could find such a move that's true
it is it's like you're on chess calm and
it plays the worst move so you can now
win yeah so what was a little Jacob rook
F to okay horrible okay that's though
it's better with the rook on f1 this
makes sure the King can't escape now
black has several ways to end the
funniest win is Bishop takes d4 only
computer-related you cannot yes
you know he's really drunk he was drunk
with power
Brooke f2 is the stupidest move ever now
the reason he played it if I could read
his insane mind is he wanted to run his
king away King f1 king he - there's
nothing it wins yeah so Queen takes H 2
wins the most obvious variation is takes
Knight Shaq discovered check with the
rook and then checkmate so white
wouldn't do that because that would be
bad for white so white would play king
f1 and then Knight g3 check is good
there's other good moves to and then
Queen g1 check is good there's other
good moves and what black sups v I think
or something so black is completely
waiting because ridiculous and somehow
black has a big attack rook F 2 was very
helpful now if you if you played up some
random legal move like rugby 1 for
example now this doesn't work because
the King just saunters away okay and
whatever I mean like it's a position I
guess if you take this and win my queen
then White's a piece ahead so probably
good for white so the only way Queen age
2 works is for black white just set it
up with rook F - genius Gavin - how he
did it
okay and now black has other winning
moves also that equalized instead
consequently the worst legal move in
history after the worst Lika move in
history just sit one-up them okay but
there's a lot of blunders this game
coughs keep playing
93 threatening Queen takes age to mate
now if I was calm ski I would be
lecturing you guys now but I would see
that there's only one defense to Queen
h2 that actually defends h2 Grandmaster
Ken west how can you defend the h2 pawn
and protect it
you can do it well maybe not
that doesn't protect the pond that
pushes it yeah obviously Preston knows
bring the night back and black resigns
although he didn't resign he was winning
later but that's different
so obviously calm ski didn't see 9 f3
because then his move was insane
he just didn't see that you could
retreat boo so 93 is the worst move ever
and now you have three whites completely
winning plus a lot 5 ok but he's -5
later because of the worst game ever so
calm ski sees his queen is hanging so he
moves it away good job and white takes
the free night then whites a piece of
head ok ok
Queen h5 threatening a queen h1
checkmate with advantage so that's now
reasonable and now white can be plus a
lot he plays some move nothing one was
the worst move on the board night who 9h
4 is a good move then your big plus
there's some of those +6 somehow he
played the worst move how do you play
the worst move every move on him play
the worst move here he waited to move he
had chill a little bit King f1 yeah
that's the worst move yeah yeah King F
one's the worst move then takes
threatening the rook I think he played a
blunder here - he tried anyway I guess I
could take the rook but he played rook
c2 and now blacks winning again
hooray King III Queen h6 check repeat a
little bit and Queen d1 because if they
repeat Tomsky wins the match so pause
for effect
illness trick would have repeated BAM
okay yeah I wonder simply repeat in
study I lost a match okay that's even
crazier what calm ski did playing
terrible it looks like I draw a I lose
the match okay
Queen d1 takes here now
any Russian grand minstrels that
overload it is because every night okay
so notice how the Queen is protecting
the knight and the rook so the very
simple winning tactic is take the knight
with a rock which may not even be the
best move but it's good enough and I
don't know this is good development I
guess and so is that all right and
blacks winning but it's like sort of
close but blacks not gonna lose so
instead of doing that his Lube is also
okay
Queen Queen h3 and now he's down a piece
but it's complicated although I would
rather not be down a piece my opinion
9gu on attacking the Queen Queen h1
moving the Queen Bishop to d5 and and
White's a piece ahead and there in time
travel and black has to prove his
compensation which he has but he didn't
really prove it jeetu and this is why
morphe was better than these bozos to
play chess now because when morphe had a
king's gambit every move was perfect
plus tax
now there's the famous game morphe
versus that guy was that guy yeah and
then probably yeah now who was he
playing it was a king it was it now not
that one it was a king's gambit and
Morpheus King went up the board and then
he took all the guy's pieces winning his
queen and they put it on on a computer
computer said more if he played perfect
every move they put this on a computer
in the computer broke they had to buy a
new computer because every move was the
worst move and the thing is there's two
ways to win at chess you can get
positions you play really well can West
knows what I'm talking about
well maybe he doesn't and the other way
is to get positions your opponent plays
badly and after this game runner Harvey
and I were talking the Grandmaster
residents currently thought this is my
one-year anniversary thank you the Ronin
said calm seas terrible tactician
horrible although I'm not horrible all
right but Audie
sleek on skis a great strategist and a
great positional player his tactical
play is a little iffy so she will not
pick the good opening to have his
opponent make a lot of blunders also she
made a lot of blunders so it was
wonderful
rook f2 and calm skis not used to tricky
complicated positions he wants it simple
that's why he should have won his piece
back and at some point why it's just a
piece up and black has no pieces and has
to resign I hate when that happens
yeah a cop's keeps moving just sort of
random moves he's not putting pressure
on the king he's not queening he's just
like well this is a normal-looking move
but he's down a piece so down a piece is
bad then there was no real fight here
he's at down a piece a checked him a
couple times that's pretty good
yeah the ammonia attack nature and here
calm ski he's dying because he's down a
piece for no puns so night and four
versus four and he had enough and there
were five moves in that game which were
at least five or six pawn blunders which
changed the evaluation and there were
two moves that were 10 pawn blunders
okay and okay
you guys know what I'm talking about
that's your kind of chess yeah kind of
lessons like that's it the best player
in China right now is one of the people
you've heard of you've heard any of them
what's that exactly gesundheit and wayy
is how old 14 and he'd beat me palm
notch in round one and share of in round
two
two players over 2,700 yeah but he would
have been over if you'd won the match
okay she refused to be good and then he
decided he wasn't okay he's like uh not
good anymore Wei Yi on the other hand
plays great he plays like a 14 year old
now she Rob also plays like he's 14 but
he can't calculate like he used to
so he blunders a lot now so they played
a Sicilian and actually if you remember
the match I'm assuming that your
only hope and even you might have some
trouble there was a match a long time
ago between Nakamura and car yakun
naka destroyed I think it was four and a
half one and a half that's correct
and in many of the games we saw this
style of play white sacrifices a piece
for three pawns and gets three pass
finds that was in several of their games
in the Sicilian variation and Bishop
takes b5 and if you look at the car ya
cannot go where a match this happened in
like half the games this Bishop e5 95-96
trade Queens and we have three pawns for
a piece actually most of those games
were drawn even though they're really
double-edged now in my opinion which
Shroff obviously doesn't agree with when
you play a 14 year old Chinese player
you should trade all the pieces off and
grind them down in an endgame because
they have no endgame experience or any
experience and Chinese players in
general the book on them is all tactics
and all theory shear off likes to play
really tactical so he plays into his
opponent's strengths
even though she rubs 100 years old he
should have some endgame acumen Bishop
h3 for example for example but instead
sheriff plays the craziest line of all
time to see who could play crazier well
then we saw what happened so h5 b5 King
on the center so white sacrificed a
piece takes on d6 with the Queen which
is actually necessary here if Knight
takes then Queen B 2 is coming and then
they traded Queens then White has three
passed pawns for a piece but the passed
pawns aren't really queening yet but
give them a few moves the hill Queen and
this was a fantastic game from Wei Yi
and he starts pushing his pawns
Bishop check takes and knight takes is
very dangerous because of rook takes
Knight on g7 really dangerous
Sally King G 594 defending his pawn and
King decides not to get mated and black
just doesn't have enough play the
typical tactic from a young player one
that you would expect sure I probably
missed co-op was actually in time
trouble if pawn takes Knight rook takes
Knight and if King takes Knight f5 check
so I'm sure that Schwab just didn't see
this and ends up being a million pawns
for a piece which is nine hundred ninety
nine thousand nine hundred and ninety
and black has no pawns ah too bad I
actually drew this ending without the H
pawn where was just rook Bishop in three
Rick mister versus rook in three it was
97 moves however my King was in front of
the three passed pawns and I was lucky
to draw it was a draw but it was touch
and go but the King is really far away
and White has an H pawn so there's no
way to draw well they came close and he
gave up his H pawn because the King is
cut off and the pawns are too strong
also this is really hard to play black
if it is a draw there's one way to do it
nobody can do it these are computers
like I give up a 7 King up you know I
hate when this happens
I hate when there's three passed pawns
now if rook takes pawn rook D it is
annoying and if you don't play rook
takes pawn then everything is annoying
so the annoyance stopped here notice how
the King is cut off I actually taught
that in the chess camp yesterday cutting
the King off and they're like what why
can't I just keep that one come on I'm
like gets checked they're like so yeah
yeah the kids of the camp would draw it
would have drawn easily they would just
walk through check and no problem then
we had no problem drawing yeah right
then you would have said you agree this
is an illegal move and they're like oh
now what's an illegal move so so here
here here black resigned but we II drew
easily was black and one pretty easily
with ye and when I play
fourteen-year-old tactician z-- I make
the game really really really really
boring
ah so boring even I get mad be very good
now if I can find this game which is the
zero percent chance bonafide anyway I
like a challenge because it reminds me
of that game in the opposite way does it
care about capitalization a nerdling er
right now okay okay one of my favorite
games that I that Mike shot II not my
dad ah Mike I got my ex-wife my dad my
brother and Mike shadi and I have Greg
shadi vs. my ex-wife
okay here's the game that's pretty funny
yeah that we got we got four fine gold
something and they got three shot ease
so there's a lot of stuff going on there
Greg Shaw beat my ex-wife and 16 was the
wonder I divorced her okay
terrible yeah I married the wrong one
alright black is you can't really read
it but try anyway Jennifer shot that
Jennifer's known for what kind of style
attacking Dragon Knight orphe
grünfeld sack all the pieces I didn't
hear you if I knew what you said okay
now I'm an old man even though it was a
long time ago I've always been old man
and I like Benjamin Button I'm going the
wrong way
and
I'm like okay we got to make it boring
out of Theory Ken west-style okay so so
c4 which I play often right now and then
b3 I figured Jennifer is not studying
this a lot that's what I figured
now I saw Jennifer playing in this
tournament because we're in the same
tournament this is the US Championship
and in one game she was playing Stas
Scriven sauvé and cribben sauvé was
white and played the sharpest sicilian
ever and i was like god stupid and then
I was winning my game and he was
resigning like she totally destroyed him
which by the way if you can find that
game cribben stop Jen shot a Sicilian
u.s. championship me and she beat him
and I was like I replayed Jennifer I'm
not doing that it's going to be trade
trade trade trade trade and then she
won't like that now there's a lot of
history behind this game it's a very
famous game you're all familiar with and
jennifer and i actually talked about we
did commentary jennifer they used to
have the u.s. championship and women's
is one tournament and they would say
okay you're the highest placed woman
you're the US women's champion which is
a strange way of doing it but and so
this year was really ridiculous what
happened Jennifer beat everybody and she
gained like 40 rating points and Anna
Hahn who was then annicon true story
it'll do that she was like oh and five
and then won her last four games against
other women who were low rated than her
in tied for first with Jennifer and lost
like 20 points and then apply off and
Anna won and she was the US Women's
Champion and they played for the money
and first prize was 12,000 so a
low-rated player losing points did
better than a hybrid player gaining
points because the Swiss system isn't
designed to see who finishes in the
middle right nerdling ER he's like yeah
that's ridiculous and they actually did
it like three times and it always be
some woman was crushing everybody then
she would lose to two super GM's
another woman was like having a bad
tournament with beats women in the last
row and she'd be first and I'm like wait
what what are you doing so they don't do
that anymore also they talk about doing
it still
okay so I'm playing Jennifer in the last
round and if Jen we're good friends we
teach chess in New York together hanging
all the time
Notre for 50 years and if it's a draw
she gets clear first 12,000 if I win I
wouldn't like $100 more right so her
brother Greg and a mutual friend of ours
who shall remain nameless Yaakov Hirsch
they bet on whether I would give her a
draw they may decide that and Greg's
like well he won't give her a dries
playing chess you can't just give
somebody a draw and y'all goes like with
their friends he can't with any more
money just give her a DRA she gets
12,000 so we'll see who's right not hit
not not Jakob okay so boring yay boring
okay and which famous physicists love
these boring positions niels bohr boring
the boring world of Niels Bohr okay so
boring bah
I've never saw look at Rick fb1 what's
my favorite movie the game by the way
because I'm going to play b4 eventually
it's not my rook on a1 so yeah that was
also the most boring with like it's
income now that it's boring even Jacobs
impressed Jacobs like wait a minute
what Jacobs like could you send me this
game this was more bored than I've ever
played
b4 it's like but I but I won 8-3 was my
second favorite move of the game because
I got left King f8 some mistake because
it miss places the King a 5 is a mistake
because it weakens b6 and 95 and that's
why King f8 is bad because Knight d7
check is coming Rick takes b6 is coming
king he 7
yeah I'm upon up prey a5 was bit she
couldn't take anymore
a 5 but a 5 weakens her or pawns on the
Queen side but she couldn't just sit
there and do nothing so not her style
85 was more her style also trading
pieces seems like it's closer to a draw
and the draw gets her all the money
and I tried to play as boring as
possible still and now I played Bishop
e2 if rook takes h4 what moved his white
play my third favorite move of the game
which didn't happen only Jacob knows
rook takes h4 what do we do this was not
played though Rick a1 is good I like it
but King g1 was the plan also trapping
the rook and also I retreat more yay ok
once a retreat I like it
ok she played rook c5 and I still played
as boring as I could h5 is a bad move
taking on ephors a really bad move but
again this isn't her cup of tea and she
resigned the black had no play the whole
game and the whole game was equal
computer program say 0.01 for me pretty
big advantage the point wasn't that I
played a good game or that I got a
winning position on of the opening the
point was Jennifer's good at calculating
and tactics and it really really really
boring positions I have a lot more
experience than she does at moto Jacob
has the most so I like to get a boring
position against those kind of players
and against other kind of players calm
ski for example I'd want to get an
exciting position where he could make a
blunder like Shimon I've did so in fact
I drew counts key ones in an open
tournament he sacked in exchange we're
both dating each other and so he didn't
necessarily play better than me I lost
to him once and a thousand moves I
couldn't move vas you're the Grove my
favorite player from what country you
you France very good and we're friends
on Facebook because he plays so good if
he loses a game though unfriend unfriend
if he loses again ok and he's the only
player who was curly for an O in the
world
cop no drawers no playoffs just win
every game now in Game one of this match
he's getting crushed and he should have
resigned according to you you were like
why doesn't he resign and seven was
later he was plus thirty that's why he
didn't resign and then he was plus
thirty a few moves later that's how he
rolls okay so this is game 2 Black has
to win and I'm like oh no Shrek he
played crazy to try to win then he get
beat has was beating of all time
okay so Vaughn sheers white and doesn't
play for a draw he's whiteness Sicilian
he plays sharp complicate three the
sharpest move not just das Bishop g4
this should be f1 resigns because Bishop
f1 black can't even play Bishop FA
bishops on f8 and it looks like what
other opening Justin it looks like
another opening it started as a Sicilian
now does it look like he's like
incorrect you the real Oh PES named
after who or is it whom whom from what
country Spain so in Europe it's called
the Spanish right so it looks like a
real Lopez even though it's a Sicilian
that's what happens Queen c7 what well
it was a lot different it would be 98
very suspicious now it's Fisher random a
for stopping b5 so B 6 well blacks
trying to make the game lasts forever
that white might make a mistake
look again scoffs key made about 30
mistakes ok but if I show the guards my
guy unless he loses next round then I
deny it
93 Bishop d3 Knight h2 which super
grandmaster world champion who comes
here a lot popularized 9h to in the ruie
comes your a lot world champion na
kimochi 92 in the ruie speaking of the
Rui a cargo played the open reach they
were black I've never seen him do that
never never see him do it what yeah my
never saw him do it
the correct answer was Gary Kasparov
played nihti X clam novelty against
Karpov and destroyed him
you've inure your nights around a lot in
the real Lopes evil into Cecilia as 985
has proven so black played 96 to d8 to
be 7 to a 5 so you're proud took 4 moves
to do it in to C for blocking it up f4
so varchar2 Grove doesn't say oh I need
to draw to win the match let me play
really boring like Jacob he was thinking
it ok he was lying of4 is the best move
let's play the best move because now for
I get an attack on the Kings side down
a5 is off sides the rook and a eights
off sighs and I have more space if he
doesn't take then f5 is crushing f5g
four resigns so he takes bishop is good
g6 terrible weakening the King Bishop h2
beautiful g4 again not playing for the
draw but playing the best move you're
not going to get plus 36 by playing
boring well you will eventually Queen c2
defending the B to pawn rook key to
getting the other rook into the game g2
defending the Jeep on b5 so but I can't
do anything so that's something anyway
rook f1 ignoring the nonsense on the
Queen side White's rooks are ready for
checkmate black wishes he got checked me
to disk after what you'll see takes
takes takes Queen c8 attacking the pawn
he 5 so you can see white is not
interested in drawing the game white is
interested in playing what he thinks is
the best move the knight on g7 strangely
fianchettoed is can't move and he wants
to open lines for his bishop on c4 his
rook on f1 his knight and E 5 does
everything and once black plays d6
to open up the wine for his bishop Queen
take g6 is annoying Knight d2 is a
fantastic move where's the night going B
for and rook takes Bishop is also a
threat so
saved his bishop night went to e4 and
computer said white is up I think +4
here when he's a pawn down that's good
compensation right so very suspicious
pieces here perfect pieces White's
pieces all perfect Knight d6 is coming
d6 is coming Knight takes Bishop winning
a pieces best queen d8 defending his
Bishop Queen f2 threatening f7 f5 as we
know in the business suicide yeah
opening up his own King Bishop h4
attacking the Queen d6 check Julian in
the chest camp or what black play here
very simple quick no no absolutely no no
Bishop takes Queen yeah for sure
Queen h4 is illegal while taking his own
bishop that's even illegal for them all
right but but make sure you're rolling
for this in my last chess camp that you
were not at but you would not add
there's a blitz Turk no it was it's a
15-minute tournament the kid stopped the
clock and he said to his opponent you
can't take your own piece and you're in
track then we're like alright we looked
and he was right like he kid took his
own piece anyone's a check anyway
but I can was opponent pointed that out
here's what you're doing wrong so Queen
sheiks h4 does both of those takes his
own piece Eddie's in check okay but this
is the World Cup they play slightly
better not calm ski so Bishop e6 nah nah
but the Queen's hanging on f2 oh no BAM
takes that takes that and black has a
good game except he doesn't also white
needs a draw to go to the next match is
he playing for a draw now he's playing
for several checkmates so II seven check
is winning Knight f6 would be winning
rook takes g6 is winning Bishop takes e5
is winning so white has good
compensation for a Queen Queen h4 and
kids would like that eise Evan check
King move
Knight f6 check King moves Bishop f7 and
this is annoying
threatening rep shakes g6 meet with
advantage g5 and as we were before
isolated pawns that's why black lost bad
pun structure Bishop g3 now it's not
plus 36 anymore because the computer
announces maid if it wasn't made to be
plus a lot yeah so that's the guy pixel
in the World Cup see and then somehow he
plays like that he must a new you know
yeah and I saying black resigned here in
shame I never get to do that I never
played players that way he's a
grandmaster never mind so you have I've
sealed the ground I've seen many times
and he's good I think he wouldn't be
alright in a playoff that was other GM's
four-way tie for first as is usual vos
years twenty seven twenty feet a so
after this event twenty seven fifty and
then so forth